thanks for opening
pie dating and together with my colleagues
geert well once a half people
who has that to go to has the
cursor toriel of
of by day it's you my name is laura
fly and rhythm collection of people
people small rocks smell my eindhoven
and you of course always looking for smart
people want to know in the details who if
they do they decide not only for big
multinationals hoe pees songs mechanic
money but also for that purpose cool and
that is poetry
this is t'ie two rubbers is in or  slogan
to this case we als oh sorry something
about how their eyes can help
distributor in eat organization to
provide you matter in eat here
because after 2000 people are killed by you
are very excited russians and then 16
million ar worldwide perfect it the
every  the love keeps the getting her for
simple and early september 2017
i have no honor maastricht die ardent
offset sizes and
large part of the urban year was effect
it my in the world to assist
ve  ry quickly formative eat ornish en
it's very important to quick information
about what the term i sexy die is ons
fashion island and in this case one
because i love the door is by looking at
maps of it lets images of en jones so
that of the  bar
witch house is a effect it and behold
he has it damage baking juices just bar you
can see your house so god damn is there
evert know your purse or even so
public destroyed do this is
by using
satellite images john buckets and
basically coloring  them by and that's
how the
de foto's and sea ok well this house so
that mix not such repairs to we not of
centrum student location
does matter with them that role if you die
pyncheon volunteers
where is your kin imagined it's time
consuming
labor intense and hannes who see
you as a quite boy work to color
1000 of maps nature what building
would effects and so dave al 5 vote
in this case of the red cross wesley the
details brookwood in the
became grass for the re  peopled is valves
rescue act is
settle clothing the possibilities to
automated is process and in car measurements
boy who fell became king to classify
satellite images from sister van jammetjes
by using and machinery bottle and in
this way you can train a model that
can provide all to  measure specification
of the damage to throw off before you
matter in the guests flexi through the law
cross will be able to his way my girl i
what the damages and ham
yes what helps and hermia nice
this column woods to x-ray toe
subforums
one is our late images to detect how to get
the building sal ok so
and jade wang is to see if via direct
the building what can you of material the
rough cut even though the time was full of
information about there a lot of nobility of
building to smooth help  j in subscribe
colleague
you can imagine that were made nice
show concrete gray more
we best out jensen smooth rug nothing
with there a roots record ok so something
like death by and to this tutorial will
focus on  20 classify caterpillar bet da
billion of flat
but the day on flat officially it's called
that how much other
information you have to have in an orgy party
widow don't allow the sentry gun silent so
easy maurice marriage weaning nice
title the technical aspects of what god
does  there are so many marie school teacher yes thank
you
so is the dc20 joepie classifying
individual building of sint maarten
where you [ __ ]
cruise ship or have rouge and in the
challenge
as the which you'll be classified
rust garden matériels of this individual
building's the workshop is searches
solo's  about apple talk to you step by
step half a thousand you do not think a know
how you should develop your own the
planning on which it is last
outside for the minutes then your time
and the playground yourself industrial
adjusting and see what the f exagon de
programs of  your deep humorless if
questions of course and after hour
hello stands the challenge with your perfect
nation and then you find you submit yo  ur
own moodle
in teams en they aldermen old structure
[Music]
the fortress crime doing is opening so
tutorial notebook
he is a notebook kind of heijstek
secure wil looxent excel box and
hope using it in a google cola
environment and the week and open it
ss  according to your navgate in your
web browser your google cola
and you know so it seems up get up in der
your home
double mln i did a find the
challenge and the tutorial notebook
of well again opening the tutorial has fake
blood like openings blew creature he
took  I a bite you
she has your time and double anal
for the kids the url shabby evolution
tuning books and you can open
by clicking on this step
industrial josé text self and ex kuroko
month for that cutting cells
don't do the read and write do hey all
tak you get enough to where she can use
this reference
and is kind of for systems one you
will be working on your own
the executable command you can magic
yourself
she puts the ball codes work for you  home
all style that buy gossip openings
tutorial notebook
is safe
on you must be login with your google
account
that's meditation something
where
yes
okay suffices from the wild and on the
settlement kind of ankle of your state
training you deeper in mole is that you  so
activator jpu
via a lot of fun legal cola
dual bailey action some of it
select the jeep your hardware and you can click
on this write-up
opening it and go to change some time
time and activate the cpu hardware
more complex
and this  is actually the buckets with
you will soon tutorial today
zoë van plm edge of individual building
sauce and consists of 4 dead to
the deep learning album we can
fell and indian
classify it already with a daze if you
whistle or
have and  in the challenge who already
want to classify the materials at this
book by löning so
cell blok
you actually ruud vd h or not
individually building's
bizarre patients at once  beep and your
clones slept in
bye bye executing the cell block and you want
her to cry validation set
we boot located in the temp directory on
the locations in on this google server and
the structure or or service
images and is share struggle ah as follows
this is how you like you start training that
training model or state class 5 minutes
girls think or cram structure
on the divisor time and how this is for you in
this workshop and these are immense or
can you keep that the ground set20
edition and  at the time in which a label
glasses and in their share images
and so if we structure it still be
presented in this workshop
those seeds from at scarf coomans
to their on this my
arrival fascists around is google server
and where all story  will also present
you became secure come on and
press my control enter and then let
alone gesture convolutional neural
network
so already bid with it will be using two
to develop a deep learning moral and for
those were  not yet relative
cnn the conventional network so you
against fish ss special time or zero network
and
new metrics a very pole for
classifiers
what is immo always you use already network
of just median fish or fries or
thousands of features what for
classification
the number fries  critical response about
million
so way features that the
ordinary mionet fix what you get there
but able to
door puppet show party and for box pdf
and too stuffy and empty is the convolutional
is like oh where the colonel network
access megaphone and in assigns
i  a multitude of professional network
without extract useful information old
van buckets and die views number features
with this part of the conventional
network
just made a professional project two
parts gives advices learning horse and
you often s vacation park with food
cycling learning park gyu extract
useful information own numbers  the
right number on bicycles and that moment
i just use an ordinary girl netw  ork
layers
judith aspiration en
in send you can also use the fantastic
i adore him search as user en en for
solo support at the machine frinstance
that my language use professional
networks so instruction drivers then
couple or read the perks or chips
and box poor was the garden  for you fast and
tasty and men and who brings a two year old
mare classification with
and for a scene and to be able to
perform a long cast occasion test that is
not so olive is all
dirty diapers
yes spaces 13
something on the mouse
for optimal advice points sharia because
so optimally sprinted is based on your
own
targets from a this case the individual
with us on Sint Maarten have to be able
to optima is albus parameters and
specially facade of promise you might
not do millions of images and nice
party  her sister big divisors time and
divide situations d hey starfam to
health
because frans kohlen and fine-tuning so if
she the team giganews an auditorium what
i essentially  don't check with the means is that
were using
the phosphate for alarm who care download
and retrieve the information that
slayer sandisk spaces already optima
forma dismal and perimeter a lot of
20 million kind of da points so that are
very well trains
to readers and sissies white floating from  the
drift this model 3 2 moodle
and then who read atom classification top
of that the players that
strand extension only exchange and
fine tune sorry transfer the handrails for that formula and find you a box and was dead dead leathers to be able to classify there
oil object of  interest
so is in this case the shakes of or of
sibling
that's quite imposing film supported
so that finetuning it central and find
you in this tutorial
a few because its beautiful formation of a
deadly him so de this link
i play style joël and finetuning en
fans elephant had my very easy and
sucked him at the pride alliance times
as an intenso pro
so if there are horses thousands
for us  ing
ts a tender about this tutorial
and like a site we can find you our
wetransfer handrail of but that formula
or coats of a find you own and
classification is empty and there for those who
did not decline off course and thea 6 that is
after all sharing  generators with can be used
to video then did the training see so
bright colors and the next built in that
after all it is you to eat 30 your
real-time augmentation and arm and
tation
care and layers your details so
you it is also simple and  the french
are related white for the image
another site where i make your argument against your
suffering big the season and zoom out to
i flip it
i take a create a ladder waller lot
more images of this is a man after all just
some argument day and they  called
pope meet the training with the and yes
like was your butt tits expensive out
under glasses real-time off and dation
amicable at such you need to the
foundation the front en wal
local these images into memory
kreas  that you sander fly and make up very
efficient you fly the training and that
is actually bought this cold blood was
so in here who does create
after all part it can know is for the
chainset and we specify the often takes
on premises and we also specify you
preprocessor function meanwhile pushing
up fans of handrail party wii
so a mole or the internet they talk
sex
useful information at images but they
say what hi-fi eksept inputs
out between sulaiman fingers ben of
course a straps if we don't have the be
processed
5l it  start signal man so dasty
preprocessor function not typing curry
oil on alarm a party for the two
cents for the window this and test that
melody salaf and against
and near you be specified in mystery that
you know me of one of idea of ​​set
skilled labor are you  see here
another cell block and choose
dysfunctions link the augmentation process
the fun phases and on the google server and
here with the bird
flew from the whitley with it whoever
specified being direct who is it is
the put to local file system of this
google-server
evo to know and how to this real time
off intention to specify the bee zeiss
was vers 5 days size
knowledge to push it has the fan of handrail
park  advice was traction
layers acceptance image eat blood and meat
rianne at 300
there still corsa ribbons if not
again ict there input such dysfunction
designs on the generators
so this time as is able to his real
time off a party and their here
yes to a cell  block
time
nests see the sucked for outside
excuses come on you can see the excel
images
the public not downloadable
so in us sexy after all is a man tube
energy ashore
aerial image aerial view of
individual building's
and the label a house so so the flat
building
a new verhip building
also be created date after all generator'
object
start is built in the train for
learning couple and find you bar
that is really solid park where your image
where ever that pla  nning murmur and
lose it show you can choose between
3 the find is for learning models
you must is the crib 16 inceptioned feedly
and the exceptional and dozer 3
public email available cnn en
van barry or to image just did set
durable that's the door  base of millions
of images and the pacifier
love bunting success is going to be dead
table and chairs and yes that is that
feature expression parody slayer with
franssens
there became me is this a colors and
parents
also use full protesten keesje but that's
why we use
bustransfer  handrail part on top of that
samsung impact b arrow and flash tv show
takes
with sexual and so room block
so then white times as
applications library
new identity of using desaever
library your garden fcc wal en to use
at least a week die 16 architecture'
all  one to a great sense is optima
for the emotional time but a moot
interest in so to prestigious
I frankly also me respiration has
a form of express for me  sie 5
all service at zwolle read that speech
will soon become a lesion do not and
do not do the two name anymore
but wearing
experts extra classification earlier
dieseltjes ordinary well just we stayed
there had to leave
all the broom all output datjes
reshaping all the tax authorities  must sharks
became ardie images into one [ __ ] and back
to number and that's why specify
occasionally out hornet i dance leo and ordinary
foil connect the army or pregnant sexy
the gives sex nose and ears long and
mount be dance leather or two note and
member to know mirrors attestations keesje
pair with your classes idols flute or
have
that's why i and artistic genius to leo
the two note
zo this part of the tutorial image of
china mobile and the beast on part
layers and who it is this men alicia
listening room  serbian army will run
run the way litter live show that is
not the beats wind
the [ __ ] minus
what is you would kia's defines the veils
you want to use and professional  members
sent time within the group
oh yes ok bali correct classification
layer
in the convolutional neural network that
we who so long your image to the locomotion
and city training or chest and right
wayne's
inn where you see the fit generator' with
the
what i for  you can be chic you
know fittings with the that [ __ ] come
paleo moral and with campanile men
see every race wood two and all that
curdle so a little smaller loose function now
training it will be an optimization be
using and also and your validation with rick
will you  because your route for the user
next edition or the link or so also already
times as a gift box that would provide with
the
definitions that love you training we
will just camp movie if you
will you our time out i want you to
a fat mosey and  the depth 200 watt
white small is conversion faster with
moodle and she percussion and you because then
local this information between you can you
so come press and kidsdeals the time
so also all
times as callbacks  so who sat then
function unchecked of the for
training pleasant i was one bottles
bowl polls model is a young man who is
for new york t race callbacks
compiling then in this cell block so in you
who actually call you find the privacy of
so in you who who download at preach 100
network
and who from widely respected lawyer
show down a great time and with that c
but come pilot and use this los passion
to optimize wit
so the cupboard i know in the cent on teams
there is a super your garden
the models crusie us cream
so and cel blok defiance the the time as
callbacks and three weeks i have nice to
stijn the belgian link via skybox in
care be afraid is you
actually your information in the single
file copies cissé freefall en girls
century already  m
if the app 3 address and or training by
the modder secure see
to the train satin this site as long as the
pilot objects function
well you and france is as if the de
so during the cissé violin eyes and if
we c the mill  heckpoint callback cases
for in the mode premises and justice
single fail
and death and death and edf 5 times more
specifically the aloe or or built jesca
bax it is and report die guy folder
myself would the callback will be using
this tutorial and this is the special  time
or or or callback
the course is displaying all of you log
in prem it is with dashboard and you pull
the dashboard called it and they board it
software development and slide celsius
perry and but integrated will you have
to fill in deep learning
two
by the  fault yes that is this and she drill
that guy broadside show
validation jersey and objects value of
redemption chanel them for the train set
and of this set if your mouth is out more and
statistics the you want to compare
deepen but if you do it out and
as it is here is my top coat to
you i actually
measure from the railing on the mizen long
train
lieke night and if you won't what is so
the know do that such here and so
save code who how you  really crazy page
logical
that discourse callbacks and silo average
sharepoint the tents board
call back and helping the date and
here we are there the times time because of
course if you want to compare this point
two now won't be out june i would take
be wise  dynamics icon about white
and their family week and city ring
this is then a cell block and a new
who
applica love the adolescents that of functions
and crime training the motor white dot
generate a matter of his way to the fine
the model one in the three  out of the duration so
transferring park
danny come pole and statue
arancini mill
or so generate the
die so calmly abandon that in every
object and all beale's or time in two
so you sit with the
and dashboard or the function and is
comment and dyscalculia
until if they offer extra parameters for
your vision know with the someone to pay
more attention to wall
the samples of less recent classes
combination of the schie by the duf and
drowsy and  do you ex i want you so self logical
from this
your morris separation in this case be
trained for 5 it creatures like firefox and
i and something app also difficult in this case
dirty pages of images you want to
increase in or out rations
the student friezes number of  app boxes
here she needs a quest number or
tube views per workout hangs and then
sweet increase the step step up
then this is the leg you can
tripod elevating the two songs as if
arms loose
everytime you don't juice the boar and and humor
the path  here
and you know double dam you because once you we
so if you can and all reese the matrix
dat yolo bye ok if callbacks
can be visualized in here so
tractor dashboard
so far in ice tooling [ __ ] i got family
how it is and u see the new
the total structure of the count
and the mud you will
so squadala to see oil and motorcycle ride
is the pi trains along with the tendon a
professional network you download
from that internet a minute them around oil
that is that st  on read already who's it
all those kinds of things da of the preprint
on morrell
with really knows all tooling
terabyte and she flow wants ehealth in
music the batmobile
on for your problem this is actually
all land ec for this tutorial raina
if on yes this  his troops of yourself
missed john notebook starling city like
a crash and start changing the van prem
it's a ci elder like a changing in
so the stem support dashboard
and of course a
your can rios almost any time of function and
baby the finest ritual  but yobi
images in your roon deep their morals to
i can this point or
respiration problem and then open it is
tutorial notebook
the challenge notebook you can use your app
you so one thing so
you and frail cool cool cool
app and website and the people  nl and for
the url and are you open the spy data
challenge materials notebook of them
have ever charlie en notebook
barn i you we and they are specified
all the printer she can choose from this
and develop en fittin  gen self and
tomorrow and i am the chance to show
them will
girl the performance of all of your set
with the moss we have in the pender test
set with you with you can do not see by
week en zo
reviews with show model and will be able
to use them all and my dear crusie
anders in the pen and test set and that's
how we will and measure the performance
of of thus him in the woods and i think
it's best way to work in teams and here
it's notebook
when you find you guys  real wine
models you can put it in the last
cell block and easy can specify your key
take and the mill that habits with and
so wil upload car with libie in
swb at will be using for the cypher
being and so think of ice tea  my and
aan al so
e-mail
is taken up in the videos there is a the team
to to to people and a wall and presented
you the e-mail is busy youth center
simon en moaning and known the
challengers you and more darling of
balance so the winner of the challenge
and public
and dorothy from angola purple pride such a
joy
[Applause]